[Music]
fantastic thank you really do you look
stunning thank you and congratulations
who recently had your third child a boy
yeah yeah have you losing your mind I
have two children and my wife at the
very thought of a third was like this is
what all I can handle
okay let me tell you something she was
right I definitely you know we wanted a
third we had a third I wouldn't trade
him for anything
but you know how to feels like six three
just put me right over the edge like
just right I was going up to any one
people on the street and saying will you
come work at my house will you please
come and just help me just take a child
just make do something okay that's bad
you've got to stop doing that you should
ask them a couple of questions yeah I
can't wait till her third child looks up
this footage and sees that you think of
him as a horrible mistake you said when
you have three it might as well be six
my mom had six she would not agree I
understand that but anyway one day I
kind of looked around it was like what
are you all doing here I'm fine goodbye
I ran into you not too long ago you and
and your husband Ben we were I forget
where we were down in Santa Monica I ran
into you at some event and he had this
crazy beer he did that he grew for the
movie Argo Wow yeah and and he he had
that beard for a while and he's looking
mad there did your I had a beard awhile
ago and my kids flipped out they hated
it it scared him he they hated it just
because it's scratchy um I liked it I
was I liked it but then the weird thing
is when it all goes and you feel like
there's a different person in your house
and you feel like Oh backup I don't know
exactly who you are could have been one
of the 70 people you hired in the gas
Starbucks now and come on so you'd be
okay with him growing it back if he grew
up back whatever sure you know what I
mean yeah whatever it I patched beard
pirate it okay
take him how you get him now this is
interesting for a family dynamic not
many people can relate to this but you
have a film butter that's gonna be at
the same time as your husband's film
Argo which film do you tell the audience
to go see if they can only see one
that's a tough one
yeah well butter comes out the week
before Argo
so definitely go see butter first but
then definitely go see Argo
so you're saying see both of them
multiple times yes
butter it took my producing partner and
me four and a half years to get butter
made and out and we love it and we're so
proud of it and it's really fun and
funny and you're gonna love it
Argo is one of the best movies of the
year I mean I could sit right here and
we could do this whole interview about
Argo is fantastic butters is too that's
very impressive what you just did you
just plug two movies simultaneously I
want to get my money's worth I'm here
for a short time and go real estate you
want to say